SPEAKER: We are pleased to
announce the 1.0 release
of the play billing library.
This library includes
convenience classes, as well as
a wrapper for the
billing service,
allowing you to
focus on implementing
your app's specific logic.
To use the library, begin by
adding the following dependency
in your [INAUDIBLE] file.
The next step is to create
a billing client instance.
You'll use this class
for interactions
with the in-app
billing API, including
listing available products,
starting the billing
flow for in-app products
or subscriptions,
opening the Google
Play payment screen,
getting users' purchases,
and creating or modifying
subscriptions.
When creating your
billing client instance,
you'll need to set up
purchases updated listener.
This allows your app to receive
updates from the in-app billing
API, like transaction
results and updates
from payments started
in other devices.
Here's the code for
creating the billing client.
Remember that it's required
that you set up purchases
updated listener.
After you have successfully
created the billing client
instance, you are ready
to start sending requests
to the in-app billing API.
It's just a few lines of code
to get the details about a skew,
or to start the purchase flow.
For more details
about billing client,
purchases updated listener,
and the full documentation,
check out the play
billing library page.
If you want to see
a step by step guide
about how to implement
the play billing
library in your project,
visit the training class.
For details of how to use the
play dueling library, including
support for Android
Wear and Android TV,
check the updated version of
the trivial drive v2 sample.
We also prepared a blog
post as a quick start guide.
And don't forget to
check out all the docs.
Thanks for watching.